irène chaigneau propose voyage sans
passeport
non
il y à 2001 des hommes vivaient dans ces
plaines de l'afrique de l'est et formait
avec la pierre des outils c'est ce qui
créa le commencement de la civilisation
la modernité de nero line cachent des
reliques vieille de centaines de siècle
à mort ghezail des ustensiles d'attentes
vieil âge de pierre gisent en grand
nombre à la surface du sol les sommes
fiers ces outils dans leur premier
effort pour s'élever au dessus du niveau
des bêtes sauvages c'était l'âge de
pierre afrique les hommes étaient
chasseurs
ils s'abritaient dans des cavernes
et aujourd'hui un point et à qui
l'homme artiste est aussi vieux que
l'homme artisan la preuve regardez
et les hommes fabriquer des flèches de
bois pour abattre les oiseaux et le
petit gibier avec la venue du fer des
lames pu rajouter aux flèches elle
devait des lances
la trappe haru africaine qui peut bien
dater d'échec lé point historique est
utilisé par le chasseur d'aujourd'hui
elle est faite de dimensions différentes
elle peut attraper n'importe quoi de
l'antilope jusqu'à l'éléphant une corde
à noeuds coulants est placée à
l'intérieur de la jante
dès qu'un animal a posé la pâte à
l'intérieur de la route ces efforts sert
le noeud autour de sa patte
tenue en arrière par le morceau de bois
à l'autre effet l'extrémité de la corne
il est à la merci des chasseurs
ces hommes sont de la tribu turkana il
se déplace en famille et avec leurs
troupeaux à la recherche de pâturages et
d'eau
durant la plus grande partie de l'année
les lits sablonneux des rivières son
secteur mais le pâtre sait où il peut
trouver de l'eau au dessous du sable et
choisissent bien leur endroit et creuse
profondément
les turkanas sont nomades et en quelques
endroits qu'ils aillent leur première
tâche de trouver de l'eau chaque famille
fait son propre trou d'eau à l'intérieur
de l'étendue du camp
et ils doivent s'approvisionner à la
fois les gens et le bétail
de jour en jour les troupeaux sont
menées au chant vers de nouvelles
pâtures mais ils ne peuvent trop
s'éloigner de l'endroit d'un breuvage et
lorsqu'il n'y a plus d'herbe à proximité
la communauté se déplacent entièrement
pour trouver de l'eau ailleurs
c'est cruche à eau sont en peau mais la
plupart des substances il domestique
sont en bois
le chef de famille crache pas qu'une
caisse de bois qui contient son
principal habits de cérémonie
en plumes d'autruche et une corne pour
son tabac les femmes turkana portent des
chemises en peau qu'elle prépare couches
des décors elles mêmes elles sont à la
mode et de mémoire de vivante la mode
n'a jamais changé là-bas
ce sont des cultivateurs le premier
fermier qui brisa le sol filles avec ses
morceaux de bois et aujourd'hui il le
faut avec une lame de fermer sa forme
est demeuré inchangé
le chef de la tribu habitait dans la
case les devoirs ici habité poulet et là
c'est le grenier à grain
ce sont d'excellents vanier on trouve là
bas toutes sortes de taille de forme de
peigne et
ils les ont mais non marché et il s'en
sert pour emmener d'autres choses aux
marchés
sont fabriqués avec des matériaux très
simple
et depuis des générations il n'y a pas
eu d'innovation
ils ont un très très grand sens pratique
et chaque sorte de panier façonné pour
épouser une forme particulière
ils ont des vanniers avant d'être potier
la roue du côtier est inconnu là-bas et
le pot effet de boucle d'argile enroulée
l'arrondi est donné par la torsion du
choc
un dessin est imprimé dans l'argile
molle
et après la cuisson les potiers color
leur travail avec de la terre rouge
et une fois que le pot est terminée il
peut être utilisé sans crainte pour
travailler au dessus d'une flamme
l'africain de l'est a fabriqué la
plupart de son équipement familier avec
le bois la hache plate en fer qu'il
utilise est mince
sauf le tranchant avec lequel il peut
abattre les arbres en forêt quand
l'arbre et abattu il va sous cette forme
chez les travailleurs du bois
là-bas le bois est extrêmement abondant
et il est pas ne pas besoin de craindre
de lombez pillés
quel que soit le genre de travail qu'ils
font ils le feront solides ils le feront
bien fait
les canoës sont taillés et creuser pour
les pêcheurs des côtes de l'océan ce
type de canoë semblent dérivées des
embarcations ancien amené à madagascar
par les colons indonésien il ya environ
mille ans
chaque équipage de pêche possède 9 ou 10
filets de pêche
ils sont largués immergé à une courte
distance du rivage
les africains de l'est n'ont pas
d'embarcation d'océan ils n'ont jamais
été explorées les hautes mers
et leurs canoës conviennent parfaitement
au travail qu'ils doivent faire ils sont
rapides stable répond souvent les plus
légers
l'eau des fonds tropicaux à baulmes de
poissons à tous les niveaux les filets
reste au fond à une profondeur de 10
bras ses environs la hauteur d'une
maison de six étages
et chaque jour la prise est tiré à la
surface avec des cordes de vignes de
forêt
voilà
les seuls l'embarcation qui effectue est
servi sur le lac intérieur cative sont
les radeaux primitif sur lesquels des
plaques de sel sont remorqués du lit du
lac jusqu'au rivage
les marchands autour du lac victoria
transportent des marchandises dans des
deux rouges de style arabe
mais la plus soignée et la plus belle de
toutes les embarcations elle est
africaine et le canoë utilisés par les
pêcheurs dans les eaux du nord du lac
victoria
là pour une fois il ne s'agit pas d'une
construction massive une feuille de bois
et dessiner la coque est faite de
planches de chaque côté le tout est
tenue en forme par des pièces entre
croisé aucun métal est utilisé dans ces
bateaux
les morceaux sont cousus avec du fil de
fibres les coutures au boucher avec du
papyrus et calfater à l'aide d'un coton
imbibé d'huile
la preuve du canoë prolonger rend le
contrôle du bateau plus aisés par temps
orageux dit on
non
les pêcheurs navigue le long du rivage
et pêche avec des filets fabriqués par
eux
durant la saison leurs filets peuvent
être déployés en vue d'être réparé
couvrant d'immenses surfaces autour des
huttes du camp de pêche
il ya aussi là bas des pêcheurs
clandestins
iman chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport
cette émission a été réalisée avec le
concours de caltech c'est de solange
pétel son annick v10 le cul périgny
montage pierre michel rey illustration
sonore denise glaser